la tercera fue la vencida para la
tranquilidad de los responsables de la
NASA
la misión artemis 1 un vuelo de pruebas
sin astronautas que orbitará la luna fue
lanzada con éxito en Florida en la
madrugada del miércoles pero no Todo fue
un camino de rosas ya que una fuga de
combustible hizo temer que el
lanzamiento fuera aplazado por tercera
vez sin embargo los ingenieros lograron
solucionar el problema para alivio de
los cerca de 100.000 asistentes muchos
habían viajado con antelación a cabo
Cañaveral en Florida para ver el
lanzamiento que representaba una
oportunidad de presenciar lo que
denominaron como un momento histórico yo
era demasiado pequeño para ver las
misiones Apolo Así que quería venir al
siguiente lanzamiento que iba a ir a la
luna quería estar aquí en persona
la cápsula orión que se desprendió del
cohete Poco después del despegue hará su
viaje hacia la luna
en lugar de aterrizar en la luna se
quedará en una órbita distante
aventurándose a 64 mil kilómetros detrás
del único satélite natural de la tierra
la misión se prolongará durante 25 días
con un aterrizaje en el océano Pacífico
el 11 de diciembre
el lanzamiento es la primera etapa del
plan de la NASA para llevar a los
humanos a la luna después de 50 años que
incluirá a una mujer por primera vez
algo que si todo va según lo previsto
tendrá lugar con el proyecto arte mis
tres en 2025 lanas espera establecer una
base en la luna con un objetivo futuro
más ambicioso alcanzar Marte enviando
astronautas al planeta rojo en los
próximos 20 años